okay so now again I make my little
heading test differentiability okay now
we've already graphed this so you should
be expecting a particular answer but we
still want to show what that answer is
the condition for differentiability
requires a derivative so I'm going to
need to differentiate this guy
it's a piecemeal function so
unsurprisingly it has a piecemeal
derivative right I differentiate one
percent domain and I differentiate the
other for the different domain so here's
what I'm gonna get actually that one's
pretty bad but anyhow it really is just
practice don't worry I've drawn many
thousands of thousands of bad curly
braces before I arrived it yeah okay
sure
what am i done all I needed to do you
there just this simple two different
[ __ ] right 3x squared negative 1/2 X
this guy just drops off okay
Olinda go through the same process but
I'm just gonna do it further derivatives
right so I'm gonna say the limit as X
approaches let's go from the left first
says negative 1 from the left okay all
dy on DX well which derivative am i
interested in from the left I am
interested in this through part I
because it corresponds to this graph and
you can check out the domain to verify
that right so I'm interested in this
limit
need brackets there's no denominators
there's nothing stopping me just
evaluating it right so I'm getting - -
not surprising because look it's
dropping like a rock as you approach
from the left now I evaluate from the
other side limit X approaches negative 1
from the right from above of the
derivative and then I carefully look and
obviously it's the other part of the
piece malfunction that I'm interested in
okay so what am I getting here weird
what happens that negative 1 squared
it's just 1 so I'm getting - they don't
match in fact they are opposite to each
other okay so therefore I would say la
de la la is not equal to its
corresponding derivative from the other
side so therefore it is not
differentiable correct
it's differential you can show this in
fact um let me just reiterate it is when
you go ahead and you test it for x
equals 1 positive 1
yeah that's right when you test out I
mean we can just quickly informally
rehearse it right now for x equals 1
what's happened to this this will be 3
times 1 minus 1 it'll be 2 and then 4
this would be 2 times 1 which is 2 so
that's why you get this smooth curve
actually happening there right so x
equals 5 it is differentiable and
everywhere else
absolutely exactly yes that's exactly so
so what I did was I introduced you with
pay please draw this right because this
were these are functions of sufficient
ease that you get a picture and then
that picture informs you as you go
through this and you can anticipate what
the answer we've been but it's not that
hard you could do this you could craft a
pair of functions or some piecewise
piece of rubbish right it's like I have
no idea what this looks like and this is
your tool right you're like I don't know
if it's gonna be smooth I don't know if
it's gonna be differentiable there so
you go through the nuts and bolts and
then you find out it is or it isn't okay
and then you graphic a cue from that
good question any other questions
yeah yeah so we will get to that in turn
four
actually um in the past when you were
drawing a cubic right
if the cubic look like this you had no
idea really where those points where you
just hide so it gets okay but now you
know at calculus the the significance of
these two points is if you will draw a
tangent you get the elephant agents the
tangents here and here will be
horizontal which corresponds to a grade
of zero right so if you find where the
gradient zero where the derivatives are
zero then off you go in fact with this
one you can pretty easily see to solve
for this being equal to zero you're
gonna get x squared equals 1/3 so you're
gonna get x equals plus or minus one or
root three who knows what that is but
that's gonna be these um
X values and then you can substitute it
in okay we will get to that later on
I didn't mention one more thing because
it wasn't relevant to this question but
it would be relevant later see how we
did continuity and then we moved on to
differentiability yeah obviously if you
are not continuous like a desert break
you can't possibly be differentiable
right like our non-technical adjective
not attitude synonym for differentiable
smooth I actually talked about this
entire rational functions right it's
it's smooth or it's not smooth now you
can't ever be smooth if you have a break
right so if at this point you're like
I've proved it's not continuous you
don't need to go any further slow
continuous can't be different
transcription yeah okay
the last one sure yeah okay like if it's
not one like if it's not continuous it's
that's literally what I would say I'd
say you know limit as X approaches a
I'll pick a number
pick a number like zero it's not equal
to the limit as X approaches zero
positive that or by the way in exactly
the same way see how I need all three of
these all three of them if I do these
two and they're not equal doesn't matter
what the last one that you've already
proved that they're not equal so these
two are equal therefore it's not
continuous in this case I've had zero x
equals zero therefore like literally no
more no more deduction between them
therefore not differentiable continuity
is a precondition of differentiability
so you've got to have the first to get
the second